I have for you today one of the dumbest
political news cycle stories of the last
72 hours and it has been drama between
Democratic candidate for the house
Alexandria Acacio Cortes and right-wing
radio host Ben Shapiro
I know Ben I've never had any contact
with Alexander
Acacio Cortez and with peace and love
I'm telling you both of their
contributions to this drama have been
really really dumb and if you haven't
heard about this I'll give you the 60
second summary Ben Shapiro offered
Alexandria Acacio Cortez a $10,000
donation to either the charity of her
choice or to her campaign now it's sort
of an unusual offer the idea of saying
to a candidate for a position I'll
donate to your campaign if you debate me
but it's fine for ben shapiro to make
that offer if he wants the legality of
the $10,000 campaign contribution of
course appears to be not legal the limit
is $2,700 but okay I guess it could be
2,700 to her campaign and you know the
rest who charity of her choice in any
case Alexandria didn't reply she didn't
say yes or no she simply didn't reply
which is perfectly fine for her to do
she has no responsibility to reply to
Ben Shapiro she's running for Congress
he's a right-wing radio host she can do
whatever the hell she wants or nothing
at all when she is offered a debate
period but then Alexandria Acacio Cortes
likened Ben Shapiro's request that she
reply to cat calling on the street as
sometimes happens as often happens as
happens all the time
all over this country and all over the
world she said on Twitter just like cat
calling I don't owe a response to
unsolicited requests from men with bad
intentions and also like cat calling for
some reason they feel entitled to one
this is very silly okay
she's right she owes Ben Shapiro nothing
and she's not saying that expecting a
response is the same as a cat call she's
saying expecting a response to the
debate invitation is like expecting a
risk
- cat calling but why are we even
talking about cat calling and I made a
tweet about this over the weekend and I
ended up deleting it because I got
jumped all over by people on the Left
saying David it's have you heard of
simile have you heard of analogy it's
not the same as cat calling expecting
the response is similar - I kind of
regret having deleted the tweet I
reflect reflexively did it and I always
say you really just shouldn't delete
tweets and for a second I thought oh man
I must have really missed worded this
let me just delete it and start over I
regret doing that now but a lot of
people saying it's not the same as he's
not saying it's the same as cat calling
fine but even bringing up cat calling D
values criticisms of actual cat calling
that takes place so here it's already
gotten really dumb in my opinion but
then ben shapiro jumps back in with
something that's just as dumb calling
the mention of cat calling a slander of
him okay he tweeted discussions and
debate are not bad intentions slandering
someone as a sexist cat caller without
reason or evidence does demonstrate
cowardice and bad intent however once
again slander colloquially is making
false and damaging statements about
someone slander legally is making false
and damaging statements about someone
that are rise to the level of I don't
know I guess you would call it civil
liability in some case Alexandria Acacio
Cortes didn't slander Shapiro or
anything close to it she didn't even say
he is a cat caller
or he is like a cat caller she said the
expectation of a response is like the
expectation of a response that cat
collars may have it was one dumb
statement after another it became this
massive story Pat where every media
outlet jumps in and I'm sort of glad
that the timing was over the weekend so
that we had the ability to let it all
shake out and see the dumb comments from
both sides instead of just commenting
like on her catcalling comment or just
commenting about the invitation which we
likely wouldn't have done the entire
thing now has now put together sort of
the totality of the picture and as you
can probably tell I don't care about her
not debating I don't care about her not
respond
or the offer what's interesting to me is
how quickly it devolves into nonsense
statements from both sides and as far as
Shapiro is concerned how can someone
with a law degree like him call it
slander just doesn't make any sense
I think this whole thing is a total gong
show I think Ben Shapiro should have
made the request in the first place I
think it's fine it certainly helps him
in his brand right and especially
because Alexander II Ocasio Cortez
doesn't want to debate him because you
know at a time or because she feels like
that's just 2 below her profile or a dad
make him look strong right or it doesn't
contribute to her winning her election
in the 14th district of New York right
well yeah be a perfectly reasonable
reason reasonable explanation for why
she's not going to do it and if
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes really just
isn't interested in debating ben shapiro
she could have just stayed silent on the
matter right not tweeted anything back
at him and in the meantime the
hangers-on like right-wingers candice
owens and charlie kirk if they jumped in
and they said hey we can get even more
money together if she'll do it or saying
that they debate her and again i ended
up in the middle of this on twitter i
said listen I'll debate any of these
people nobody has to pay anybody right
hundreds of people saying let's do that
Ben please debate David or Candice
please debate David not a peep from any
of them and you know what they don't owe
me a response I'd be up for the debates
but they don't owe me a response well
Ben Ben Shapiro has been on for an
interview and the topic of gun control
although it has been some time since
then and then we heard from one of
Charlie Kirk's publicist - about yeah
him on but that kind of fizzled out yes
it evaporated into thin air sort of like
Donald Trump's foreign policy plan or
whatever analogy you want to make I'm
really thrilled to tell you that today's
program is made possible in part by
better help calm slash Pakman as many of
you know I have been working very hard
on this program to reduce stigma around
mental health to reduce stigma around
seeking help and I have a family that is
very involved in mental health and if
you've not already heard about better
help it is a tremendous resource better
help gives you through your phone and
computer affordable private access to
licensed trained
and accredited experienced psychologists
counselors therapists and clinical
social workers who were dedicated to
helping you through whatever is going on
in your life you just go to better help
calm slash Pakman fill out a
questionnaire they will match you with a
counselor that will work best for you
they are LGBT friendly you can even say
I want a counselor who's not religious
if that's important to you if your
initial match isn't a good vibe you can
switch to a different counselor and the
beauty is that not only do you get
unlimited counseling over videophone and
text from at home and on the go it is
way cheaper than in-person counseling
and after three months it becomes even
cheaper for you they also have financial
aid for people who need help paying but
you get the same professional licensed
therapy that you would by going to
someone's office and I believe that so
many people would benefit from therapy
whether you're dealing with an acute
situation in your life whether there are
bigger picture difficulties that you're
experiencing please consider checking
out better help calm slash Pakman it's
easy to sign up and get started we've
put a link in the description if you're
watching on YouTube once again that is
better help calm slash PA que ma N